foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is
scp-2675 object class
ketter
special containment procedures
containment efforts regarding
scp-2675 are suspended the anomaly is to
be destroyed on site engagement of
scp-2675 is optimally conducted by
aircraft as the anomaly has proven both
Elusive and advantaged against Naval
units neutralization procedures are to
be focused on complete thermal
destruction of the vessel
reports of Maritime disasters and
unusual incidents are to be monitored
with primary attention directed at the
arctic Northern Atlantic and Northern
Pacific Oceans see reconnaissance filed
26.75 for details and areas of special
attention satellite observation of the
aforementioned areas will be maintained
continuously civilian or military
contact with
scp-2675 requires immediate
implementation of grade 4 media blackout
protocols and the deployment of an
aerial response team from the nearest
practicable facility General piota
vinogranov Security
42675 will direct the assembly and
operations of the aerial Response Team
non-foundation survivors recovered from
scp-2675 events will be administered
Class A amnestics
description
scp-2675 is the severe an Arctica class
nuclear-powered Icebreaker constructed
by the Soviet Union in 1977. official
records from the Russian Federation
indicated that the severe was retired in
1992 due to a steam system malfunction
however documents turned over by the
grup reveal that the severe was lost
during a mission in the Arctic Ocean
investigating a believed anomalous
artifact
although
scp-2675's current appearance is not
significantly different than it was
prior to its 1992 disappearance The
Vessel May spontaneously change shape
and produce additional structures
equipment or Weaponry
scp-2675 generates varying levels of
neutron radiation and is frequently
observed to produce a pale blue glow in
surrounding Waters believed to be
charenkov radiation in addition to
traveling in a mundane manner The Vessel
also possesses a second form of
transportation this second method
consists of
scp-2675 holy Vanishing from one
location and manifesting elsewhere the
nature and limitations of this ability
are unknown though it does not appear to
detriment
scp-2675 and coincides with a momentary
increase in Neutron radiation from The
Vessel
scp-2675 is sporadically encountered by
military and civilian Naval vessels in
waters of the arctic Northern Atlantic
and Northern Pacific Oceans occasionally
being spotted as far south as the sea of
akhotsk the Gulf of Alaska and the North
Sea
scp-2675 is hostile and extremely
dangerous though its aggression seems
secondary to a primary objective the
nature of which remains speculative
no crew or other Personnel have ever
been observed on or inside
scp-2675 however previous encounters
with the anomaly have determined the
existence of a discrete entity now
designated as
scp-2675-1
scp-2675-1 is believed to be the
vessel's captain or controller and while
the entity has not been visually
identified it has communicated with
civilian military and Foundation
Personnel via radio
scp-2675-1's voice is consistent with an
adult human male and the entity is
fluent in Russian French and English
scp-2675-1 is both hostile and highly
intelligent making use of scp-2675
stoutness and anomalous properties to
compensate for its lack of military
configuration
engagement log 2675 Alpha
on November 7th 1995
scp-2675 was observed by numerous
civilian sources in the Bering Sea the
nuclear icebreaker's presence was not
immediately thought to be unusual given
its close proximity to Russian Shores
and Arctic Waters eight hours following
initial observations
scp-2675 made contact with an american
commercial vessel and engaged with
extreme prejudice reports intercepted by
Foundation Personnel in Anchorage Alaska
described numerous anomalous Properties
exhibited by the Icebreaker these
reports were redirected immediately to
the regional superintendent's office
upon order from the regional
superintendent Foundation contacts at
Naval Base Kitsap in Washington state
deployed the ultimate an early
burke-class Destroyer to the Bering Sea
notes the Oldman maintained radio
contact with Foundation contacts at
Naval Base cat sound throughout the
mission which coupled with recovered
video and audio recordings have allowed
for a largely reliable record of the
event
begin log
unknown contact
identify immediately or be destroyed
twenty seconds of Silence
known contact
identify immediately or be destroyed
yeah
repeat
[Applause]
Americans you want to know who am I
am Herald of God
clarify
I sail for the God child born of the
atom
My Flesh burns with the light of his
knowledge
I am no longer alive but time and energy
is that answer enough for you that is
indeterminate you're responsible for
numerous civilian casualties and must be
detained allow yourself to be escorted
into our custody or be destroyed the God
child does not desire this and neither
do I
I alone a master of this ship and only
God can direct me
surrender yourself or be destroyed there
will be no further communication
scp-2675 transfigures producing two
large devices resembling microwave
emitters on its starboard deck the
Altman fires an rgm 109b Tomahawk
missile at
scp-2675 however the target vanishes
prior to contact missile detonates
underwater
scp-2675 manifests at point-blank range
to the Altman ramming it on the latter's
port side the Altman suffers significant
damage but opens fire on scp-2675 with
its Mark 45 artillery and m242
Bushmaster cannons while Under Fire
scp-2675 directs both of the
aforementioned devices at the Altman
grew aboard the Altman report the
spontaneous appearance of many
transparent and luminous humanoid
figures which as determined by the
onboard decimeters all produce lethal
levels of ionizing radiation at this
point
scp-2675 has sustained Grievous damage
from the bombardment and breaks away
heading north the Altman continues its
assault until
scp-2675 vanishes again
end log
in the aftermath of event 2675 Alpha two
sikotsky's ch-53e super stallion
helicopters were deployed to determine
the status of the Altman and search for
survivors it was determined that all
Personnel aboard the Altman were killed
either by
scp-2675's Collision drowning or
radiation poisoning analysis of
recovered video footage indicates that
Personnel suffering radiation poisoning
from contact with
scp-2675 displayed atypical
symptomatology including transparency
and Luminosity of organic tissues and
emission of torrent cover radiation from
the eyes due to interaction between
charged particles and the vitreous humor
at the time of its next recorded
appearance the damages sustained by
scp-2675 during event 2675 Alpha were
seemingly repaired and noticeable
changes were observed in the vessel's
structure
investigative report Carmichael excerpt
in may of 1996 several former grup
operatives were granted asylum in return
for the relinquishment of numerous
documents including those pertaining to
the severe service history reports
indicate that the Icebreaker was
utilized by the grup for reconnaissance
and transportation of materials between
installations in Northern Russia the
vessel's last recorded mission in 1992
entailed the investigation of an
electromagnetic anomaly in the Arctic
Ocean contact with the severe was lost
four days into its Mission following a
final radio transmission from the
captain
the nature of which was undetermined at
the time the following is a recording
transmission
it's a crude cradle small and weak but
it is all that my ship could give him
the truth is that we were not looking
for him he was looking for us he found
us looking through his Frozen cocoon we
looked at him then did not know or
comprehend
I broke open his cocoon and held him in
my hands I burned but did not feel pain
my men and I were reduced to Ash in the
snow Without Eyes we could truly see
without flesh we could truly feel
I felt the love of God I Saw the Light
by his majesty in this nuclear age we
can think of only missiles and power
plants but there is something purer
inside all of us
we are atoms
the God child sits in the heart of my
ship and he will take us on a long
journey
when I return I will show all men his
love
and I will find the other children that
sleep in the sea
event 2675 November
on July 8 2005
scp-2675 was observed in the Greenland
sea attacking a fishing trawler the
entire incident was observed by a nearby
personal sailing vessel the owner of
which testified that
scp-2675 rammed the fishing trawler
causing the ladder's Hull to breach and
the entire ship to eventually capsize as
the trawler was sinking
scp-2675 produced several devices
consistent with those seen in event 2675
Alpha and directed them at the capsized
vessel during this process numerous
meteorological disturbances were
observed and an aircraft resembling a
rigid airship in the sky emerging from
cloud cover upon the appearance of this
aircraft
scp-2675 immediately ceased its previous
activity and produced several
unidentified and unprecedented
structures all of which it then directed
at the aircraft both 2675 and the
aircraft began and to sustain severe
thermal damage with no identified Source
after several minutes both participants
disappeared but not before the sailing
vessel received a radio transmission
from
scp-2675-1 It is believed that this
transmission was broadcast in an
extremely high amplitude and on all
Marine VHF and aircraft Band frequencies
as it was detected by various other
marine and aerial recipients over an
area
below is the recording of This
transmission
scp-2675 was not observed again until
eight months following this event it
showed no signs of damage but
demonstrated a significant increase in
Neutron radiation emission the anomalous
aircraft has not reappeared in
conjunction with
scp-2675 or otherwise
during his interrogation the sailing
vessel owner turned over several
phonographs he had obtained of the event
which included some images of the
aircraft after investigation it was
determined that the aircraft's
dimensions and markings were consistent
with them A zeppelin developed by Nazi
Germany in 1943 as part of an
experimental nuclear weapons program the
is known to have been carrying or
integrated with an anomalous object
unidentified in available records
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you for listening if indeed
you still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Big sip
zargaron
oh crap guy
James sama
braided Peach
fire of prime
Dr Wolf 13.
copster
worthy fire
zazapan
Irish wristwatch
signor
a la trayon
your local Foundation agent
and Lost Boy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you